ich habe ja bis glaubt nun nötig sie
stehe die narbe hätte eigentlich wo die
burschen
haben
das sind manche sagen sie sich falsch
therapiert wurde die schreckliche
erinnerungen
psychotherapie suggeriert worden es sind
falsche er in riga simoncelli der it und
glaube daran dass sie fremd störe sie
dass sie bewacht werde beobachtet und
umsorgen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gibt es
für diese ausgestaltete theorie einer
großangelegten verschwörung
satanistische im hintergrund gibt es
keinerlei belegt dass die er für
schwierig so celik in der schweiz
kursiert haben wir unsere reportage im
dezember 21 aufdeckt dass ich vorn
braucht
schlachten wollte schnitts maschinen
nach mindestens tausend opfer
wir haben zeigt dass offenbar auch
standen die psychotherapeutin die
erzählung oder teile davon glaube wir
reden da von menschen opfer blut trinken
aber ich schon mal gehört also wirklich
alle grausamkeiten die menschen ersinnen
können
finden dort statt mit zeigt jetzt was
tiere schwierig erzählt gerichtet wie
mancher wo hilfe die psychotherapie
sucht man eigentlich sieben jahre von
ihm lambert verloren
nach häuser letzte harry potter
überzeugt einig panik in der schweiz ist
viel passiert sind medizinexperten
entstanden wo festgestellt hat jeder
schnitt haben wir das problem mit der
regierungszeitung und zunächst nicht es
hat sich nix mannschaft wurde wog seit
an dass ihnen die absurde geschichte von
der elite elektrotherapie suggeriert
worden und genau die menschen die welt
gebracht
message sektor facebook nach der partie
schoss geworden ist wurde in stadt mehr
hat ein psychiater immunzellen einreden
wollen dass es ebenfalls so gewesen sei
also mit das auto nicht
[Musik]
also ich bewusst eine grünzeug
begeistert dass ich zwei therapeuten wie
zb eine geschichte erzählt und da ist
denn aus mehreren gründen ausruf oh wow
also du musst doch fortan ist er
missbraucht oder sie und ich habe
überhaupt nicht vor dem zeit es ist auch
ganz sicher nicht der fall und das immer
wieder wellen geraten und haben hätten
also sachen aufgriffen
kompliziert brauchen kann da die narbe
hast du eigentlich war die botschaft
wurden wo sie irgendwelche sachen unser
geschnitten und dann ist heute drehte
dann aber und musste betreut vor dem du
musst auch lieder nachdem du vertrauen
ist das noch komischer moment ausführe
und ich
ziehe das ist wenn dir einer
wahrscheinlich meine frau und ich
war einfach nicht quasi
erstickt sie wählen die eine
persönlichkeit die ein bisschen
passieren ja also ich bin nicht nur
bauarbeiter sich abgesprochen dass ich
mir einfach zu sicher
also werde ich jünger sie hat das ganz
schlimm kann's gar den weg zur
verabschiedung und hat so zu verzaubern
na ja also ich werde nicht mit 15 auf 17
[Musik]
zum glück hatte dominik die geschichte
von damals atheistische rituelle
missbrauch nicht glaubt aber es gibt
andere wie dem gedankenkonstrukt den
stecker und ich frage mich einfach wie
kann das passieren
[Musik]
der frank urbaniok ist eine von der
renommierte psychiatrische ferenczy
kritisch mit er beschäftigt sich seit
über 30 jahren mit sexual und
gewaltstraftaten schön als man glaubt
nicht so ein schönes thema ist
unentbehrlich sind
also wenn das so passiert ist wie es
dargestellt hat wird dann sind das klare
behandlungsfehler das muss man ganz klar
sagen und es ist ja in der psychiatrie
und psychologie mal ganz wichtig dass
man ergebnisoffen daran geht dass man
realitäten zur kenntnis nimmt aber nicht
dass man irgendeinen glauben eine
überzeugung eine theorie in die
patienten hineinprojiziert weil man
selber daran glaubt und so wie das hier
geschildert wird ist das genau das was
hier passiert ist der therapeut ist ein
dienstleister für den klienten und nicht
jemand der den klienten
instrumentalisiert für eigene
überzeugungen oder theorien die hat du
sagst also ganz klar da werden diese
ideen suggeriert vom therapeuten aber
wir sind immer wieder auf menschen
getroffen die gesagt haben doch ich habe
das erlebt diesen rituell missbrauch es
gibt schwerst grausamste form von
sexuellen übergriffen und sexuellen
missbrauchs gibt auch sexuelle
übergriffe
die mit rituellen aspekten verknüpft
sind das alles gibt es was es nach
jetzigem kenntnisstand nicht gibt sind
organisierte zirkel akku ändern die im
hintergrund verschwörungs mäßig eine
große satanistische
unterwelt organisieren in der dann
patienten kinder spezielle missbraucht
programmiert werden letztlich so ein
verschwörungs szenario das gibt es nicht
da gibt es keinerlei belege
es geht darum ob es schreckliche
sexuelle missbrauch gibt da gibt es die
organisierte dass gott die verschwörungs
erzähl ich von der elite vom untergrund
hinter quält und sie so programmieren
dass man sie immer wieder missbraucht
und das ganze mehr ausgeglichen
ein völliges
bzw zudem
verdient ihre marc schreiber dass ihre
tochter lebt vor zwei jahren die
therapie city und sie schrieb ihr
zustand verschlechterte sich jedoch
laufend bis sie uns unter absoluten
geheimhaltung auflagen eine geschichte
erzählte welche sich mit den inhalten
ihrer reportage vollständig deckt in
unseren köpfen entstand ein ungerechtes
spekulationen über personen in unserem
bekanntenkreis
außerdem tatsache gemeint dass
irgendwelche
bekommt es aber nicht das sind worte
[Musik]
sollten speziell was hat das mit der
maus größten diese reportage es ist zwar
kühler grand
casino die paranoia was ich habe
angst sie hat für sie wir programmiert
machen zu rollläden 8
sie hat am morgen schmerzen
sie hätten keinen stau das hat die
ausnahme ist sie das sehr stark macht
und erstaunt ich jetzt mit kleine
ausnahme hannig nur die stand es ist vor
ca passiert mit meiner tochter
arbeitet therapie auf die idee gebracht
hat sie sich auskennt fatalistische
circa missbraucht und umprogrammiert
worden so dass sie jederzeit zur
verfügung stellen sie ist vier mal xii
vier mal drei oder vier minute und aus
gelangt dort ist er erst wirklich
schlecht gegangen mit seiner lässigen
mit suizidversuch mit psychosen oder
umbringen wir sind für hacker hier curry
zu der böse hier angst muss man sich mal
vorstellen wo die leute da moment
empfindet er
hat mich gefragt warum
diese gibt mutter und david käser sowie
der mutter sieht der sieht ja
potentially täterin irgend einer
fachperson muss doch sagen
wie verrückt um die welt dass das
aufhört
das beispiel wo ist die mutter erzählt
zeigt für schwierigste celik ist nicht
nur einzelne psychotherapeut es problem
sondern das geht offenbar sogar auf die
trams station vor der renommierte
schweizer klinik littenheid der tochter
von bettina wurde vor ihrer einweisung
in die klinik in littenheid eine
dissoziative identitätsstörung
diagnostiziert eine sogenannte dies sehr
auffällig dass praktisch alle opfer die
auch für diesen satanistischen ritualen
erzählen auch eine so zone des
diagnostiziert bekommen haben hat diese
dissoziativen identitätsstörung im
zusammenhang mit der verschwörungs
erzählung und was ist das genau ja also
ich glaube man muss hier präzise sein
man muss zum einen feststellen es gibt
die sozia tivi identitätsstörung das
bedeutet ja dass sowie ein
überlebensmechanismus der persönlichkeit
ist wenn etwas ganz schlimmes erlebt
wird etwas traumatisches und sozusagen
alles schlechte in einem
persönlichkeitsanteile abspaltet und da
kommen wir zu diesem fatalen moment oder
der idee der programmierung die bedeutet
ja oder das ist auch in dieser
verschwörungstheorie tischen erzählung
so dass man sagt ja da gibt es super
intelligent es gibt zirkel die haben
methoden gefunden wie sie dann
persönlichkeitsanteile in dieser die
sozia tiven identitätsstörung also
dieser abspaltung von persönlichkeits
anteilen die können das programmieren
und dadurch haben die wie in einer
fernsteuerung zugriff auf die menschen
sie können diesen teil aktivieren sie
können dadurch den menschen zu irgendwas
veranlassen was er nicht will sie können
erinnerungen löschen und das ist ein
element was erzählt wird was letztlich
aus diesen verschwörungstheoretiker
narrativ stammt und auch hier ist es
wieder wichtig es ist nicht schwarz weiß
dass man sagen kann ein opfer können
nicht manipuliert würden
selbstverständlich mit mit
fürchterlichen strategien und methoden
aber sie können nicht psychologisch
programmiert und damit wie ferngesteuert
mit 60 mv gerade gefragt mal darauf
gesund phase reportage sich liebten auch
bis vor drei bis vier jahren hätte ich
eure reportage als treten reale
propaganda abgetan wird weiß sie aber
dass sie selber die verschwörungs erzähl
ich geglaubt hätte vielleicht wenn sie
satt und therapiert worden in dem drama
station sie will aber unbedingt glaube
im übrigen wenn sie nämlich schon
verständigt braucht weiter aber trotzdem
wenn ich sagen kann ich mache
[Musik]
ja schon fast zwei jahre gibt sich latry
karriere hing am lkw newsletter heck
hobby buchholz bevor er flieht der hobby
hanni extreme angst story entwickelt
dass sie nie muss im hobby und ich habe
nicht damit gerechnet dass es heißt die
könige nachmieter haare aber nach jetzt
doch der sieht hier genau richtig
dringende verdacht durch die sozia
identitätsstörung
sie zeigt dass ihre austritts bericht
vor der klinik die drin ist vor täter
loyaler persönlichkeitsanteile und
vorprogrammiert dreht und ganz ungestört
probleme durch negative
kindheitserlebnisse rezidivierende
rituelle sexueller missbrauch außerhalb
der familie
das müsst ihr wissen und darum
stadtoberhaupt von der familie aber
trotzdem hat der kaiser dessen stern
ihre
bezugsperson resch wenn die mutter dem
vater gut zu mir gesagt hatte wer hat
die kritik
er hat den wahlen 2008 also englisch
warnt im ersten radikale kontakt zum
mittwoch die haspa jacke kontakt zu
ihrer familie cover getan wie völlig
isoliert wurde ich habe ja mit partner
es ist immer besser es ist so schwierig
da der kontakt abbrach und es ist so
toll dass sie das geschafft hecke und
habe mich gut gefühlt bedankt habe immer
das richtige
mini2 größte angst war der zitrone tee
trinkt
cbot irgendein ich erinnere mich an mega
schlimme sache überleben und andere was
ich
[Musik]
jedoch
schlimmste sache
wenig fantasie
ich habe mich vor christus erinnert ich
habe ja angeblich strom volk trägerin
red oder also situationen wo
irgendwelche höhle es fehlt noch ein
anderes steht und mit kaltem wasser
abgespritzt wird und ein von der prd
suche
ist humbug ist nicht passiert ich glaube
er hat bewiesen dass glaube die einzige
was man uns antwort bei hunden ist dass
die diagnose der babysitter an schienen
schreckliches auch erlaubt so schwarz
ich so ziert und irgendwann musste ja
die er in russisch wird in aix und für
die diagnose sie übrigens mit
körperlichen schmerzen nicht
diagnostiziert wurde meine schmerzen
gewächse die mini traumata verarbeiten
aber sicher aus trauma assoziiert
jahre nach der therapie sicherheit ist
patricia zum eine neue therapeut gange
der hätte denn all dies muss
diagnostiziert dank der diagnose dort
besser sagt sie doch der von den beiden
also via patricia sind vor zwei jahren
mit dem verschwörungs erzählungen liegt
in kontakt gesetzt aber die
kriegstreiberei gesagt dass ihre gute
freundin fügt in therapie ist in letzter
zeit und immer noch das
gedankenkonstrukt glaubt und sie aber
mit initiiert eine freundin hätte
gemeint hätte sämtliches zeichen dafür
dass ihre opfer vor die
touristen nicht einmal irgendwie im wald
behindert verbrennungen der bcg sie
gemeint sicher nicht irgendwelcher
schaffen und ich möchte irgendwann
irgendwas erinnere ich meine ich amis
bruch in der vergangenheit erlebt aber
ich weiß was das vermisst praktisch
unabhängig ob das klappt oder nicht ganz
wieso
es ist so dass wenn man weiß wer ich bin
ich bin wieder penetrant belagert wird
eine war die geschichte glauben genau
dass sie gas wieder zeichen das opfer
bin
als mann gottes wenn du mit eur hedged
bist du selber als opfer weil die
satanisten mit ihren anteil ausgelöst
hat wo quasi als gäb's das nicht genau
das gibt es möglich die schon
programmiert zu mit dem media weiter und
die geschichte ja ja es tut mir hat mein
kwc das mini freundin nach wie vor das
klappt und das gefühl die frau als ob
sie viel kränker sie wird kränker als
ist ursprünglich sie ist
und das gefühl dass die
therapiesicherheit schon 30
sie hat vor halb psychische probleme
aber definitiv nicht gehe was jetzt
bereits nach dem gespräch nur messages
zeigt so deutlich wird wie abhängig ihre
fliegenden vor ihrem therapeutisch das
macht uns betroffen
man hat ja sind im januar kontakt mit
den flaggen verliebtheit erzählt dass
man die verschwörungs erzählen glaubt
sie wir leider nicht mehr als vor der
kamera reden wenn sie sagen stellte ihre
jobs verlieren aber sind
sie schrieben die zustand durch die
trainerstation minderheit war nimmt als
fach pflegerinnen bin ich sehr
beunruhigt die these das okkulte gruppen
durch äußerst gewalttätige techniken
menschen programmieren und kontrollieren
können ist katastrophal denn auch und
ohne jede belege werden spekulative
konstrukte als unhinterfragt die
realität präsentiert und in der praxis
angewandt
vier verschiedene quelle hand unabhängig
voneinander glaubhaft verzählt dass
patienten der klinik mitte für schwierig
sehr zäh lligen kontakte sind mit zeige
die vielfalt mit bezug zur trauma
station liegt im frank urbaniok man muss
zur klinik littenheid sagen ich kenne
die klinik littenheid kann verschiedene
stationen und da gibt es ganz
hervorragender therapeuten und stationen
die sehr gute arbeit leisten aber es
gibt hier doch sehr viele belegen
mittlerweile dass hier offensichtlich
auf den trauma stationen ein
verschwörungs theoretisches negativ
einzug in die therapien gehalten hat das
ist ja immer etwas wasser und
professionell ist und was b auch zu
psychischen schäden von patienten führen
kann weil entweder solche irrationalen
inhalte entweder erst erzeugt worden
werden oder dass eben verstärkt und
qualifiziert werden bist du der meinung
dass angehörige und betroffene einen
schadensersatz kriegen sollten für diese
viel therapie ich kann grundsätzlich
festhalten dass behandlungsfehler und
wenn es zu behandlungsfehlern gekommen
ist
grundsätzlich auch haftungsrechtliche
fragen nach sich ziehen können
während klinik littenheid mehrfach um
das interview pate und haben sie mit
alois vorwurf konfrontiert dass ich
freunde zu bekommen die thematik nehmen
wir auch bei uns sehr ernst und haben
aufgrund des vorwurfs gegen den oberarzt
umgehend eine visitation eingeleitet
dafür haben wir zwei renommierte und
international anerkannte experten
beauftragt im uns vorliegenden wie
situationsbericht schneidet die klinik
littenheid in sämtlichen punkten sehr
gut ab klinik schriebt aufgrund vom
arztgeheimnis risiko auskunft zu
spezifischen frage wie eine parallelwelt
die extrem gut sich extrem gut zu
schützen weiß so dass es sehr schwierig
ist dieser menschen habhaft zu werden
andy märz setzt klinik der oberarzt in
der erste reportage von re parallelwelt
mit unvorstellbarer gewalttaten geräte
unabhängig von der visitation von der
klinik hätte aus thurgauer
gesundheitsamt eigene untersuchung
begleitet resultat sind noch keine
kommuniziert was mich irritiert ist dass
klinik littenheid ihre räumlichkeiten
zur verfügung stellt für impulstage vor
der netzwerkgruppe rituelle gewalt und
beschrieb der teilnehmerinnen am 29
november 2008 10 öffnete die klinik
littenheid ag privat klinik für
psychiatrie und psychotherapie ihren
großen saal für 120 teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer der impuls tagung rituelle
gewalt an einem schönen ort mit
großartiger verpflegung durch die klima
littenheid ag wurde über ein furchtbares
thema mitten unter uns gesprochen oder
was die netzwerkgruppe rituelle gewalt
und rituelle gewalt dort sie schrieben
charakteristisch für rituelle handlungen
sind wiederkehrenden symboliken und
gleichförmige handlungen wie sie etwa
während kultische ritueller
satanistische magische rituale vollzogen
werden
mehr her natürlich klinik mit dem
konfrontiert wie so sieht er für
schwierig erzählt plattform land aber
auf das haben sie auch spezifische
antwort energie
man fragt sich natürlich schon wir haben
die therapeutin überhaupt die idee dass
sich manche in verschiedenen
persönlichkeiten abspalter und dass man
sich an programmierer und all das zeugs
also wir sind während der recherche
immer wieder wissenschaftliche
publikationen gestoßen
das aktuelle gewalt struktur ergibt und
das mind control
vollzogen wird
eine oder vorschreibt ist der
renommierte schweizer psychologen
psychiater jahren spezialist für trauma
therapie dort schrieb musste viele
bricht für betroffene sich schließen
dass die verschiedenen
persönlichkeitsanteile vor der täter
bewusst hergestellt werden blut einer
recherche enthalte das element von der
erzählung von ritueller gewalt mind
control mehr an die siebte mit
konfrontiert
jetzt etwas gerade riesig schieber und
so den controller bewusst der hersteller
von persönlichkeiten seite folgendes
diese darstellung deckt sich mit den
einschätzungen von interpol europol
sowie verschiedenen kinderschutzbund
europarat organisationen in
terminologischen leitfaden für den
schutz von kindern vor sexueller
ausbeutung und sexualisierter gewalt
also nicht mehr
terminologischen leitfaden ausdruck das
sieht der 15
was
überrascht die entstehenden
persönlichkeitsanteile werden für
bestimmte zwecke trainiert und benutzt
ziel dieser systematischen abrichtung
ist eine innere struktur die durch die
täter ihnen jederzeit steuerbar ist
es möglich wissenschaft
dass wir jetzt geklärt
für das treffen mit ausgewiesener
renommierter fachexperten von der upd
der universitäre psychiatrische dienst
verwenden die direktiven strikt wird
sich nie zum konkrete publikationen
österreicher sondern allgemein zum
konzept von de re sogenannte mind
control mind control ist er ein pseudo
fachbegriff das heißt ja nur dass man
andere menschen irgendwie beeinflussen
manipulieren kann das geht natürlich
aber das könnte natürlich auch
therapeuten tun das heißt wenn eine
personengruppe besonders empfindlich ist
für so etwas sind natürlich auch
ausgesetzt der der kontrolle der
manipulation oder der suggestion
vielleicht auch gut gemeinten zu
visionen von therapeuten bei all dem was
wir hören von mind control von rituell
missbrauch dass eine wissenschaftliche
grundlage
wissenschaftliche theorien müssten
widerlegbar sein sie müssen überprüfbar
sein wenn das nicht der fall ist wenn
sie immer stimmen wenn sie nie richtig
widerlegt werden können dann handelt es
sich um eine pseudowissenschaft
mind control ist also es
pseudowissenschaftlich konzept doch
genau auf dem ich die verschwörer celik
aufbaut genauso wie auf die diagnose von
der dissoziativen identitätsstörung
die diagnose gibt es dauert sachlich
verfasste vom konzept von der rituelle
gewalt und form ein control sagt einer
von 100 litern regis wenn die
technologie jurek dann muss man sagen
das sind eine bis 50 oder
0,01 bis 0,5 promille weil dieses aktive
regisseur der identität die anderen
gleise
behauptet also das wird jetzt die
wissenschaftlichen ergebnisse werden etc
[Musik]
die identität stehe auch nur wenn du
sozusagen
gleichzeitig ein traum hast das heißt um
die symptome zu erklären muss der klinik
diese dürfen also das suchen das trauma
das kann als die diagnose nicht stellen
und das ist natürlich schwierig weil es
ja dann eine falsche kausalkette und ein
logischer fehler man möchte eine diese
aktivität störung diagnostizieren kann
das aber nur wenn so ein trauma gibt und
dann wird einfach das trauma erfunden
und das öffne tür und tor für die
verschwörer celik
einzelne element von der ver
schwierigster celik gibt's außer dokus
und dies oder auch dass man manche
beeinflusse aber die erzählt votums
gestrickt wird das theater mancher mit
schlimmste gewalt gezielt spalter und
dem programmieren das hat man bisher
noch nie einen polizeilich nachwiesen
dass es einen zusammenhang gibt zwischen
regis diagnose und als
verschwörungstheorie der amerikanische
studie erwiesen wurde wenn so boltz
technikpanne gesteckt worden ist sind
auch diagnose von der dease
zurückgegangen
äußert er geschrieben und ziehe ich
nicht in liter heizöl vor sieben jahren
hat sie mit der psychotherapie abfangen
die zweite dritte 70 hätten ihre
therapeutin diese aktivität störung
diagnostiziert
ich kann das lang nicht wirklich
hinterfragt wenn ich einfach davon
ausgegangen bin dass ich eine
therapeutin die wird es wohl besser ich
habe mich auch regelmäßig mit
therapiesitzung schöne erinnerung sie
hat mit eingezahlt hätte ihre daraus und
das verzählt
es hätte sich bei ihrer art teil von mir
gemeldet die teure therapie 70 und ihre
vom ihs bruch erzählt haben am anfang
ist es nunmehr missbrauch sie irgendwann
ist satanistische missbrauchs sie
irgendwann hat kaiser ja das besteht
immer noch ich bin tatsächlich fast
sieben jahre ihre idee von lexi wenn sie
mir am anfang alles gesagt was ich heute
weiss es nicht glaubt das finde ich ja
eigentlich perfiden am 19 dass sie
wirklich so dosiert aufbaut hat dass ich
langsam immer mehr truppen und das
automatisch immer mehr glaubt und nimmer
hinterfragt haben sie hat mich dann auch
nur noch in kliniken wiese wurde die
geschichte glaubt hand zuletzt bin ich
dann halt in einer klinik oder sehr
ernst no hat und mich auch entsprechend
vor der qual tabellenspitze was ja
verständlich ist also mache ich weil er
von europa schützen wo zugriff auf die
rettung immer wieder einen die
messbesucher genau von einer
satanistische tätergruppe und es steht
sowieso wieder diagnose glaubt dass man
sich ans bett fixiert damit ins internet
seine kreise gibt es ja ganz bestimmt
die dort zum beispiel der eine 30
oktober halloween ich soll es dort um
mehr weiß das steht an schienen zur
sache passiert klinik hat um in die
therapeutin sonnenkalender büro mit orte
wo immer gefährlich sind entsprachen bin
ich noch vorne oder jeweils eine torte
zur sicherheit zu minensicherheit
einfach fixiert wurde der mitschnitt auf
die idee klingt ihre aussprache oder
diagnose
also ich war einfach kein kontakt
zu meiner mutter zum inneren schwester
zu garen jemandem er eigentlich obwohl
ich ganz klar immer wieder geriet an ich
würde mich mal telefonieren bezüglich
telefonieren hat man das so gut
kontrolliert das waren meine schwester
wo hat er von alten über station ist
immer über vor der pflegte peacock red
hat zur closed was ich telefoniere
definitiv aus ich muss sagen ich mehr
als einmal tankt eigentlich war es für
mich leicht aber nicht irgendeine
straftat wird machen und ist crailsheim
ich hätte die bessere bedingungen
wenn ich jemand kommt wie jetzt in der
situation wo minister eröffnet hat dann
wäre ich erschienen jetzt im ausland
mittlere neue identität also mir
eigentlich gerade hat ich hätte kontakt
zu abbruch nur wissen wo gott existiert
im ersten moment und ich verstanden dass
es das gar nicht erst mal ins loch
sieben jahre oder 571 glaubt nun nötig
sie stehen eigentlich sieben jahre von
ihm lieber auf einen ort verlor
[Musik]
wenn du jetzt dankt das hat auch
nützlich gesamte akte vor der liga
führen
sämtliche polizeieinsätze seien bisher
im sand verlaufen da die täter
verhindern konnten dass die xy zu viel
erzählt jeder versuch sich nicht an die
vorgabe zu halten wird mit strafen in
form von neuen übergriffen verfolgt xy
wurde vermutlich bereits als säugling
programmiert und für die zwecke
organisierte gewalt geschult die
patientin hat sehr viele
erinnerungslücken kindheitserinnerungen
sind kaum vorhanden
die akte zeige dass die verschwörungs
erzähl ich nicht nur in littenheid
sondern auch andere schweizer kliniker
und vier weitere schweizer
psychotherapeutinnen glaubt und danach
therapiert wird
noch viele klinikaufenthalt ist lea
heute arbeitsunfähig und bezieht iv wir
können zum thomas idee präsident von pro
mente sana wo sich für die psychische
gesundheit gesetzt
ja sicher etwa im see betroffen macht
oder wollte man vor der frage wie sich
jedes leben völlig verändert mit der so
schritt für schritt nicht besser wo die
psychiatrische unterstützung sondern
schlimmer wurde nicht hierfür sei die
psychiatrische versorgung zu stehen wo
es keine kontrollmechanismen gibt wo
sich verstehen dass es nicht passieren
psychotherapie habe gravierend in
aberwitziger ha und die frisch auf den
nun vor dass das thema sehr proaktiv
auge und untersuche gemacht vor schick
finanzieren und überprüfen wo ist die
therapie schädlich und sondern therapie
muss sofort gestoppt werden da geht es
nun um
wirtschaftlichkeit sondern darum dass
wissenschaftliche rat oder die kollision
in der radikalisierung verlorenen
bodenhaftung der körper etwas andere
lösungen
sie ist absolut leute das betroffene und
aufhören
[Musik]
seit einige die usa aufgearbeitet wurde
es hätte ein regelrechter tsunami
anklage geht er ab eutin ecke wo man
diese methode vorfeld
in deutscher sprache umfeld luthe
sektenexperte bis hin zur aufarbeitung
der us-märkte psychologin wofür familie
gericht gutachter schrieb sie ist genau
ist so fall involviert sie wohl die
schwierigste zähl ich glaube sie seit
mit denen über theorie werde ganze
familie kaputt gemacht
immer begleitet sie muss nicht immer
schön schrecklich schrecklich
diffus sie aber niemand genau weiss war
das ist für mich das ganze ist die ganze
unglaubliche geschichte gelangt vor dass
es dort sexuelle
um das problem dass ihnen jemand glaubt
sie stehen wozu ihr sind andy roddick
einfach ich
sprechen er wird
[Musik]
während sich das schwarz passiere immer
noch fehlt therapie in schweizer
psychiatrie drum ist wichtig dass wir
wieder an ruhiger wenn ihr euch mit
eurer betroffene straße wie sehr sie
unter deiner falsch therapiert lebte
hand und bis heute rung der lieder wie
üblich mit auf jeden fall am thema dran
darum abonnieren canal 7 kommentare und
teilen das video mit ina verhindern und
sehr steil verpasst test video zum
ersten teil bis bald
[Applaus]